[Music]
hey folks you probably got a good look
at diablo 4 during the xbox showcase
however we have a little bit of extra
footage that we wanted to show off uh
just to give you guys a better
understanding of the gameplay
specifically we have footage of the
necromancer one of the classes they just
announced as well as some pvp stuff and
a world boss uh joining me is eric tay
he is the blizzard uh diablo expert uh
so we had to get him on here to kind of
go over some of the cool stuff that he
noticed yeah thanks for having me jake
and uh hello to all the fans but it's
really exciting to see more diablo 4 of
course uh seeing the necromancer get
revealed not my personal favorite class
of of you know the diablo
timeline but you know i know there's a
lot of folks that enjoy the class and
we're getting to see kind of just some
tried and true right some corpse explode
and and kind of going through a dungeon
with just a golem which is interesting
because you know the necro is known so
much for being a sumner class and we're
gonna you know see some variations of of
the necromancer gameplay throughout this
kind of first clip um we'll kind of let
this play through a little bit and then
i can get into some of the other
stuff in a little bit
now we're out in the kind of like open
world um here different class kind of
build here you have skeletal warriors
you have skeletal mages um what looks
like maybe teeth from kind of diablo 2
or variation of bone spear
as well as some cursing going on we
don't get context in terms of like what
exactly each of those skills are the
only thing that i saw through these
clips that we got are just more about
the different variations for the the
summoning which is you know the primary
core of a necromancer um but you know i
can kind of break some of those down so
the skeletal warriors that are kind of
out there right now
are probably um either skirmishers or
reapers uh there's three there's three
variations skirmishers defenders and
reapers the defender which is the only
tool tip that we got through this kind
of gameplay is
geared towards uh having durable shield
bearers with 15 more life you'll see
some defender
uh
skeletal wars later in the later part of
this clip but um you know you can
upgrade it uh one of two ways one of the
ways you know every 10 seconds your
skeletal defenders will negate the next
instance of direct damage they would
take
if you decide to want to sacrifice it
which is one of the three options you'll
gain 15
um non-physical resistance but you'll no
longer be able to raise skeletons the
skeletal mages there's three options
there's shadow cold and bone
for example with cold as one of the
upgrades each time your cold mages
damage enemies with their primary attack
you gain two essence if you want to
sacrifice the uh cold skeletal mage
you'll deal 15
increased damage to vulnerable enemies
but again no longer able to summon
skeletal mages um and then with the the
golems there's bone blood or iron uh in
this clip you're seeing iron so i'll
just like break down what iron does iron
golem will slam the ground and stun
enemies and every fifth iron golem
attack causes a shock wave dealing x
percent damage to primary enemy and
enemy behind it that's that's one of the
two upgrades for the iron golem and then
if you decide to sacrifice the iron
golem uh you'll deal 30
increased critical strike damage um but
you can't summon a golem anymore
i've never enjoyed the summoning aspect
of necromancers even though that that's
kind of what the class does so it's kind
of cool to have this passive ability of
trading off your summons to make your
necromancer stronger essentially um but
what we're seeing in this clip is you
have the defender skeletal
warriors that i mentioned as well as
iron golem there's legendaries that
they're not picking up
presumably to you know keep some of that
hidden uh although i know a lot of folks
probably want to see what those are
and then you have either a bone spear
kind of like variant where it is
hitting the wall and then bouncing back
and kind of making three bone shards or
like smaller bone shards um
don't know if that's an upgrade for for
like bone sphere or teeth i'm not sure
which one it is that looks more like
bone spear though um or if it's kind of
like a legendary effect that's like on
one of the necromancers items right now
on on this specific character one thing
to just note a lot of that information
uh you gathered from a build that's not
finals like some of that could change so
don't take everything as gospel that
we're saying but anyway back to the
gameplay
man
[Applause]
yes
we're getting some pvp here which is
something uh they're kind of bringing
back right it was pretty big in d2 but
uh was absent in d3 yeah like it's it's
cool to see it come back uh you know
there's definitely a lot of folks that
enjoy pvp um so don't know how it'll
interact with you know what end game or
like mid game looks like or what kind of
rewards you even get from it but you
know it does give that extra flavor of
kind of builds and
gear that you might want to use
specifically for pvp that might not be
necessarily good for pve but you know is
catered to just
fighting other players
huh
all right so the last clip we got is a
world boss um and this boss looks pretty
impressive but you were noticing some
similarities to other
d3 bosses right yeah just a little bit
you'll you'll see later on like in the
clip when it kind of does some summons
where like it's summoned some treasure
goblins kind of eerily similar to greed
from diablo 3 where you know you take
your puzzle ring and and put that in the
cube so that you could get this kind of
like secret level um but yeah it's a
pretty big spectacle you know having a
big boss out in the field with um i
tried to count them there's definitely
at least seven um
characters but i think you can have up
to eight as i mentioned previously
there's the kind of the goblins running
off it saddens me that they don't try to
chase them to kind of kill them to get
the gear that presumably they would drop
but you know hey we're focusing on dps
on the the world boss here and i think
the other one cool thing that i i
noticed is it kind of feels a little bit
like monster huntery where
um you know at the start of the fight
the boss isn't as beat up it doesn't
have as many scars but kind of like over
time you kind of see a little bit more
like
cuts and and a little bit more bleeding
from the from the boss
but um yeah just just cool to have a an
open area where you can kind of team up
with other players and and kind of
tackle a big boss you know and get some
hopefully good gear
and that's it on the diablo 4 gameplay
thank you all for watching and if you
want to check out more diablo coverage
we have a couple videos on gamespot
right now including an interview with
some of the developers that i highly
recommend you check out see you next
time